>>Teacher: Okay, so let's trace
the blood through the heart.
Where does it come from?
Superior, inferior vena cava.
Coming from the where?
The body, right?
And then it enters the what?
The right atrium.
>>Narrator: This class at South Grand
Prairie High School near Arlington,
Texas looks like a
typical biology class,
but for many of these students,
failing or passing this course
can be a matter of life or death.
[ Siren wails ]
>>Narrator: On a cold, rainy morning,
members of the EMT class respond
to an accident near their school.
>>Student: Go ahead and get
a C-collar and a backboard.
>>Narrator: While the injuries
aren't real, the hands-on learning
that happens here makes
an everlasting impression.
>>Stephanie: When we first
got out there, I was nervous.
I made the mistake of going
around the truck instead
of going straight to the stretcher.
I actually followed them, and
I got there and I'm like, "Oh,
I'm supposed to be somewhere else."
>>On three.
One, two, three.
>>Stephanie: We learn a
lot through repetition.
It's great because if we mess up
on something, like if we're going
through a scene and we mess
up, they're able to critique us
and we find out what we messed
up on and we learn from that.
>>Teacher: Okay, so what
kind of patient is that?
Is that a stay-and-play
or a load-and-go?
>>Load-and-go.
>>Load-and-go, and that's
what she did, right?
She got there, she did her
quick assessment, all right?
Okay? And you got your group
out, you put her on a backboard,
and you got her in the ambulance.
Why was that so important to you?
>>It's cold outside.
She was shivering, and
she needed to be inside.
>>Teacher: Good.
Very good assessment.
>>Narrator: The EMT program is
part of the Health Science Academy,
one of five academy options for
students at South Grand Prairie.
They can prepare for college and
careers in everything from accounting
to art to engineering and law.
>>I will be representing
the prosecution.
>>Roy: What we found out is that we
weren't successful with 60 percent
of the students, that, yes, they were
graduating, yes, they were moving
on to life after high school, but
not at the level that we would
like to see them, so we decided
that old phrase "what's good
for one is good for all" and
go to wall-to-wall academies
for all 2,500 students to give each
and every one of them an opportunity
to explore, to experiment, to find
out what they wanted to do, and, yes,
to find out what perhaps they didn't
want to do after they're graduated.
>>Stephanie: It's great being in
an academy because you get to learn
with the people that want
to do the same thing.
Like being in a big school, people
may distract the class of not wanting
to be there, but when you're in
academy, everyone wants to be
in that academy and
you're able to learn more.
>>Good job.
Let's do it again.
>>Chad: I will teach you all
the medicine you want to learn,
but the biggest thing I want to
teach you is critical thinking,
how you can think in
a critical setting.
And they take that everywhere.
They take that out when they
go out partying that night.
>>Charles: All right, guys.
What do we got?
>>Student: We have an
18-year-old female.
Her initial BP was 130/70.
>>Narrator: Most of the
academies invite professionals,
like flight paramedic Chuck
Skinner, to volunteer as mentors.
>>Student: She was A and
O times 3 at that point
and respirations were still 18.
>>Charles: Kids in high school tend
to be pretty good test takers
we could give the book to
and they could pass the final exam.
That's the truth.
They would suck as EMTs.
They would not be employable.
>>Student: We're going to put
you onto the helicopter, okay?
It's going to be very loud, but
everything is going to be okay.
>>Charles: The bottom line is, we
have to motivate them to care enough
to actually want to apply these
skills to someone who's bleeding,
to someone who's drunk and
behaving badly from a head injury.
>>Student: We treated her for
a possible tib-fib fracture--
>>Charles: Rather than this
pie-in-the-sky kind of education
where we all hold hands, sing
"Kumbayah" and read soccer tees,
we actually are talking about
stuff that matters today.
I mean, they'll come out of
school ready to go to work.
We have jobs waiting
for some of these guys.
>>I don't recommend you have
your stethoscope around your neck
because when you're down like this,
they're going to be
hanging in your patient.
>>Narrator: If they do well in the
course and pass a battery of tests,
students can graduate as certified
emergency medical technicians.
>>Charles: If you can catch folks
that are very good at this type
of hands-on learning early on, not
only can you save them the grief
of spending two decades trying
to find their career, i.e. me,
but you plug in young, vibrant,
healthy folks into a system
that really needs and requires
that kind of physicality,
you improve the system for everybody.
>>If you all lead us down the
wrong path in your assessment,
you understand, we're going to
go down that path until we figure
out "Ruh-roh, Shaggy,"
we got a problem.
"Ruh-roh," and in the air, it
is a much more serious problem,
so we depend on your assessment.
>>Ma'am, do you have any other pain?
>>No.
>>Shawnda: Being able to know what
I'm doing and actually be able
to take charge and do it, it really
makes me happy, because if you think
about it, if that's a real
patient, you saved their life.
I mean, you were a part of that.
You got to save their life, if,
of course, they live, but, I mean,
you help them and you get to help
them and it's just so much fun.
>>Do a rapid trauma assessment.
>>Debra: The data that we've seen
over the time since we've gone
to career academies has shown that
our kids are being more successful.
The fact that the parents come to our
parent meetings, in droves, actually,
and say, "My kid is really
loving that EMT class."
"My kid is really enjoying studying
something that means something."
>>Good job, guys.
Good job.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.